[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben heute habe ich ein
Burger Rezept für euch das gab es echt
lange nicht mehr das Besondere an diesen
Burgern ist dass sie zu 100% vegan sind
und wir starten jetzt direkt damit
unsere burgerbands komplett selbst zu
machen so für gute Burger brauchen wir
natürlich richtig gute selbstgemachte
burgerbands und wie die ganz einfach
vegan funktionieren das zeige ich euch
jetzt und die ganz genauen mengangaben
schreibe ich euch wie immer hier unten
in die Infobox ich habe jetzt hier
erstmal eine vegane milchalternative ich
nehme heute ein SoJ drrink ihr könnt
aber auch Hafer verwenden am besten
natürlich irgendwas was nicht gesüßt ist
da gebe ich jetzt frische Hefe mit
hinein die Milch habe ich in der
Mikrowelle ein bisschen erwärmt aber
nicht so dass sie über 40° warm ist weil
dann hat die Hilfe nicht so gemütlich
und ja stirbt quasi ab und das wollen
wir ja nicht so einmal hier reinbröseln
lassen dann gebe ich noch Zucker mit
hinein verrühre das ganze ganz kurz und
lass es erstmal 10 Minuten zugedeckt
[Musik]
stehen nach den 10 Minuten habe ich auch
schon die vegane Butter hinzugegeben
vorab einfach kurz zerlassen in der
Mikrowelle und das gibt auch noch mal so
ein richtig schönen Geschmack aber auch
die Konsistenz verändert sich dadurch so
ein bisschen und jetzt kommt Mehl hinzu
da gebe ich euch den Tipp weil Mehl ist
ja auch ein Naturprodukt nicht alles
hinzuugeben lasass so ein bisschen
beiseite und dann könnt ihr das ja immer
noch nach und nach dazu kneten und auch
jetzt erst das Salz hinzufügen wenn ihr
das vorher schon mit reingibt zur heilfe
das verträgt sich nicht so gut so und
jetzt lass ich das erstmal kurz kneten
bis ein homogener Teig entsteht gebt
dann wie gesagt immer ein bisschen mehr
Mehl mit dazu und ganz zum Schluss knete
ich auch noch mal kurz mit den
[Musik]
Händen so der Teig ist fertig wenn er
sich wie euer Ohrläppchen anfühlt also
gerne einmal hier einmal gegenfühlen das
ist unfassbar schon fast gruselig wie
identisch sich das anfühlt so und jetzt
gebe ich den Teig in eine Schüssel gerne
unten schon ein bisschen Mehl mit
reingeben und auch oben drüber damit da
nichts anklebt ich mag das dann immer
mit Frischhaltefolie komplett die
Schüssel zu versiegeln und für Hefeteig
ist es auch immer besser wenn ihr ihn an
einem warmen Ort gehen lass natürlich
nicht zu warm also so ein schön
gemütlichen Ort ohne Durchzug wie z.B im
geschlossenen Backofen und jetzt darf
der Teig 45 Minuten lang gehen ich habe
das ganze schon vorbereitet undw seht
ihr hier das ist so schön wie der
aufgegangen ist schaut mal das ist jetzt
der fertige Teig und der wird jetzt
eingeteilt daraus kommen nämlich fünf
burgerbands raus entweder fünf
mittelgroße oder vier ganz
[Musik]
große so ich habe jetzt vier Burger BNS
draus gemacht dann sind die ein bisschen
größer und das ganze jetzt auch noch mal
unter einem beren Geschirrtuch ca 20
Minuten gehen lassen wenn ihr die Zeit
habt dann nehmt sie euch gerne so und
jetzt wird das Ganze bestrichen
normalerweise würde ich jetzt Eigelb
nehmen aber in dem Fall bleiben wir
vegan daher nehme ich hier wieder meinen
Sojadrink also irgendeine
milchalternative einfach die Bands damit
bestreichen und dann kommt da noch ganz
traditionell Sesam drauf ihr könnt auch
Sesam normalen Sesam und schwarzen Sesam
nehmen oder was ich liebe ist sesam in
Verbindung mit Schwarzkümmel schmeckt
auch noch mal richtig lecker den Ofen
habe ich auch schon vorgeheizt 180° Ober
und Unterhitze und da werden die Bands
dann richtig schön goldgelb gebacken und
in der Zwischenzeit zeige ich euch eine
Sache die bei Burgern auch ultra wichtig
ist nämlich die
[Musik]
burgersoße so fast so wichtig wie die
burgerbands ist jetzt die burgersoße
wenn die nicht schmeckt dann kann sie
schon mal den ganzen Burger versauen
daher zeig ich euch jetzt mein
Geheimtipp für eine richtig perfekte
vegane burgersoße wir nehmen uns jetzt
von miracle VIP die Salat Creme die ist
zu 100% vegan und die hat schon so ein
würzigen Geschmack und die wird luftig
aufgeschlagen ihr merkt das sobald den
ersten Löffel hier aus dem Glas nimmt
das ist so eine richtig luftig
aufgeschlagene Masse auf
erbsenproteinbasis und davon gebe ich
mir jetzt einfach was in meine Schüssel
und verfeiner das mit saurengurken
entweder müssen bei mir die saurengurken
in Scheiben auf dem Burger oder schön
klein geschnitten in die
[Musik]
burgersoße
zum Schluss habe ich nur noch
Paprikapulver und Knoblauchpulver mit
dazu gegeben und fertig ist unsere
burgersoße muss ich einmal kosten ich
liebe nämlich
burgersoße M M rundum perfekt also wenn
ihr gar nicht lange Rätsel raten möchtet
welche vegane alternative ihr hier als
Basis verwenden könnt nimmt Mirakel
vertraut mir richtig richtig gut und wir
gehen jetzt über zu den Burger petties
und dafür hole ich mir jetzt eine Pfanne
und dann wird schön
[Musik]
gebraten auf die Burger petties habe ich
noch veganen Käse drauf gelegt und der
ist dann schön geschmolzen das klappt
aber nur wenn man den Deckel drauf macht
weil dann richtig schön der Raum
geschlossen ist und alles schön warm ist
und dann kann der Käse dann in der Zeit
in der die petties Garn schön schmelzen
und jetzt wird einfach nur noch
zusammengestellt die burgerbands einmal
aufschneiden und jetzt könnt ihr euch
entscheiden wie ihr das zusammenbaut ich
z.B mag keine Tomaten auf meinen Burgern
ich habe jetzt hier aber rote Zwiebeln
ich habe natürlich Salatblätter aber ich
starte jetzt mit meiner leckeren
burgersoße die kommt bei mir einmal
unten auf mein burgerbann und einmal
noch mal oben drüber weil ich finde es
kann nie genug geben mehr ist mehr aber
schreib mir doch gerne mal in die
Kommentare was so eure liebste Burger
Kombination ist was ich auch sehr mag
sind karamellisierte Zwiebeln auf Burger
das ist auch richtig
[Musik]
lecker so jetzt kommen wir zum Taste
Test und ich muss sagen oh das sieht so
gut aus da musst du noch mal ran da
musst du noch mal ran das ist mein
Burger h ich finde ja optisch ne rein
optisch sieht der nicht vegan aus aber
ich probiere mal für
euch
m wow Hammer also ganz ehrlich dieser
Burger dafür dass er auch komplett vegan
ist und man ja vermeintlich Abstriche
macht was aber gar nicht der Fall ist
bekommt von mir 10 von ze Punkte ich sag
euch auch warum klar merke ich an Hand
des Pettis weil ich ja normalerweise
auch Fleisch esse dass dieser Petty
vegan ist also natürlich merkt man den
Unterschied aber die burgersoße macht so
viel im Geschmack aus also die verteilt
sich komplett im Gaumen wenn man
reinbeißt und dann hat man ganz am Ende
noch mal den Geschmack von dem Burger
Bann wo man überhaupt nicht merkt dass
da irgendwie ein Ei fehlt klar ich mag
auch Ei in hilfeeteigen weil das dann
alles so ein bisschen elastischer macht
aber dieser Bann ist so richtig schön
fluffig und hat so eine ganz leichte
Kruste also richtig lecker Leute macht
dieses Rezept unbedingt nach und vor
allem ich habe ja auch viele vegane
Freunde das werde ich den auf jeden Fall
beim nächsten Mal also unbedingt
nachmachen ich gebe 10 von ze Punkte und
sage bis zum nächsten mal auf meinem
Kanal tschüss eure Kiki ach und wenn ihr
noch mehr vegane Rezepte haben möchtet
auch gerne im süßen Bereich dann lasst
es mich jetzt in den Kommentaren wissen
bis dann
[Musik]
tschüss